welcome to this video playing bony face
v8 the eighth okay um someone suggested
also the Bangko could be part of my
opening challenge so let's go for the
bank oh oh just declines it with Quincy
to him yeah I think this is a reply not
sure if it's a good one but it is a
possible one what about a six is this
feasible maybe you take first now he's
six
if a chick here probably see going to go
'if i've probably a queen is 7 so
there's no it just takes where that
doesn't scare me that much maybe i can
even put the bishop 26 I'm kind of
inventing things yes I go along quite
clearly but okay so here's some he's not
running into this check their rookie and
check I mean age three I don't know see
concerned about bishop edge tool that's
not going to work ever okay so i could
actually i got some pressure going on d5
oh yeah so Queen to e7 for no not
helping really I wonder if Bishop b5 is
a move and then d 6 let's do that sir I
think a decent positional idea the
bishop cannot sit forever on d6 yeah
okay i'm going to take andrew create so
i'm having some pressure against e 50
this is an easy game chess right every
move in one second and 97 what is he
doing then yeah maybe I should done
Bishop g5 is tricky 97 f 6 when I have
95 so probably have 695 is nonsense okay
soon John g6 now lamb that is a pretty
weak the duck sorry has a weekend
going to H form and h5 Queens you five
minutes can't end I can end up really
badly quickly mm-hmm
Queen age six is not not such a huge
problem Karrueche eight probably this
famous last words
94 might be a problem but
maybe 90 for attacking d5 to maybe deter
him from doing that ruh cage force maybe
not sure that actually threatens made ok
wants to he wants to play Bishop evade
this is his idea hmm
Joe that's so she difficult pretty
difficult to defend yeah f6 ciao i
underst I didn't really see that Queen
g3 was coming so even with us we had
move some he manages to kill me quickly
could have played that much better of
Time Machine Age 6 is just nonsense but
I came it's probably still winning them
and made on g7
sure black resigns Jim Jim it just works
yeah it just works this this stuff I
have six I don't know I really feel and
that he should be okay here I mean this
can never be a really great opening
handling like h3 is just a total loss of
time and so on I mean even maybe the
setup is so rubbish that white can play
all this stuff and still okay but um Jim
f form and I really should be okay yeah
pieces are not that bad looking at d5
yeah 97 f six strong it's just a strong
move and I if I do something like that
Bishop f4 was sitting added that he get
gets an f5 is a really huge problem
normally it would be nonsense because of
97 but f6 is just strong so this is this
is just well played yeah antium i'm
basically losing i mean 8pb 3s it's just
candy can just do that of course i
didn't understand any mafia i-94 g5 that
kills me very quickly b3 is completely
and unnecessary but probably this
position is so bad he can do that I mean
here we should be 694 again was winning
but this probably also wins have no
defense iam maybe I should have tried
rook g8 me it loses but
still check yeah that's over we should
buy fade I cannot defending and said
it's just over so what was wrong there I
mean it is a this is not exactly the
kind of opening that I think is pretty
good but but still I think it should be
quite okay I mean moves like Age 3
mm-hmm it's just useless f3h three just
loses a move I cannot take on h2 or
whatever so it's just it's just just
bonkers but what is so how can I can I
use this in some way maybe a five pick
up a six or something the reason why I
think I should be ok is that t5 is is a
target maybe this Bishop b5 is tues to
is to silhouette that kid it's possible
well maybe we should be seven I think
black should be able to get an OK
position somehow against this slowish
build up with h 3 and so on ok maybe
Bishop d7 is not the the best move there
d6 nof form mm-hmm Bishop g5 was also an
idea yeah maybe that is just not great
or maybe age 6 I have a debt encourages
Nigeria five huh
why is this just losing a move somehow
no not really I'm not saying I'm better
or anything like that it just I cannot
really except that black is worse him
that's a bit strange really because I
got the B file open and I have something
to tag with this pawn there on d5 maybe
if I start like that now maybe this is
some this is better let's say I start
with Bishop b5 and I actually get that
get to trade and maybe this is the
better way to play like like to see here
castles and now getting the bishop off
like this we should be five maybe
yeah this is probably okay it's probably
better than the bishop on b7 is not a
particularly great piece yeah itm that's
strong f6 is just a strong move it's not
difficult really but I saw that solid
far too late how effective that is Jeff
and T I'm toast a women especially could
have played that much better in one
quicker but ok winners the winners a win
so it is just a very bad position ok
well thanks for watching